un nouveau témoignage important dans la
sphère dils un ancien policier de metz
ne croit pas à la culpabilité de patrick
dils cet homme condamné à la perpétuité
pour l'assassinât de deux enfants alors
ces policiers estiment que la piste du
tueur en série francis heaulme n'est pas
à négliger
un témoignage qui intervient 48 heures
avant l'examen d'une demande de révision
de ce procès explication valérie ermite
avec estelle mathieu à france 3 nancy au
maire stragier est un ancien policier
en 1987 il a assisté à la reconstitution
des deux meurtres en présence de patrick
il n'a pas oublié ce qu'un autre
policier sur place
à la fois le jour du crime et pendant la
reconstitution n'y avait ce jour-là le
brigadier s'assure j'ai constamment et
se révoltent et même contre le fait que
l'on ne patrick dils en quelque sorte
finissait par faire tout et n'importe
quoi et notamment sa / g de voir que les
petites poupées qui représentait à
l'époque les victimes qui doivent être
chargés de remettre en place
ce n'était pas comme ça tout aussi
troublant le témoignage de ces trois ou
quatre vieilles dames qui se sont
approchés d'homère stragier pour lui
faire part de leur étonnement quant à la
physionomie du meurtrier
l'une d'entre elles s'est avancé vers
moi je suis on commence un peu vers elle
et puis elle me dit tout de go à leur
monsieur c'est donc pas le vieux
monsieur que nos vues fait que sa
bicyclette à l'époque des faits patrick
dils avait 16 ans et n'était pas en
bicyclette
francis heaulme en tueur en série
notoire était lui en vélo ce jour là ils
n'avaient certes que 27 ans mais son
visage n'était pas celui d'un jeune
homme un témoignage bien tardif d'un
homme que la conscience aurait fini par
guider c'est aussi le cas de marguerite
posocco
elle était sur un balcon le jour du
meurtre et aurait pas perçu patrick dils
se rendant aux poubelles
j'ai vu monsieur dire venir avec un sac
sur le dos via ce moment-là qu'est ce
qui s'est passé ben lui la villa il est
rentré chez lui hier c'est à dire que
vous êtes en train de dire qu'à aucun
moment il ne s'est dirigé vers les
enfants jamais jamais jamais jamais dans
deux jours la cour de révision devra se
prononcer sur le cas patrick 10 une
décision d'autant plus délicate que les
magistrats ne sont pas en possession de
ses nouveaux témoignages